what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
the mcu has a new chronological order
lineup disney plus has revealed and
updated the official chronological order
and has told us the official way to
watch all of the films from start to
finish of the mcu now there are 33
projects in here and i say projects
because some of them are movies and some
of them of course are disney plus shows
and some of them are actually one shots
some of you may know what the one shots
are they're quick little clips that are
usually only a few minutes long but they
just give us a little bit more context
of what has happened in movies or tv
shows and there are several of these now
listed on the chronological mcu watch
order and again these are posted to
disney plus which means they're actually
kind of crucial for the watch order and
disney plus is stating you need to watch
them and i'll be talking about when
spider-man far from home and no way home
take place in the mcu as well as when
all of the marvel disney plush shows
take place because they're not in the
order which you would think so we have
the new official chronological watch
order for the mcu let's get into it and
see what it is and of course if you want
to stay up to date on marvel and the mcu
be sure to subscribe now like i said
there are 33 projects here however there
should be 36 because the spider-man
films are not listed because of course
they are not on disney plus because sony
owns them but we pretty much know when
they take place so we can throw them in
there that's no big deal so the first
one i know there has been some debate on
which movie you should watch first for
the mcu well disney is coming outright
and stating it captain america the first
avenger is the first film that you
should watch if you want to watch the
mcu in chronological order now the
second one is where they throw kind of a
curveball the second one isn't iron man
or captain marvel it's actually the
short agent carter it's a 15 minute one
shot where agent carter joins shield and
battles with her boss agent flynn and
according to marvel this is the second
thing that you need to watch and it is
worth noting that there are several one
shots but not all are included on this
list which means some of them aren't
canon to the mcu specifically the one
shots team thor part 1 team thor part 2
and team daryl then we get to the third
project that you should watch which is
captain marvel from here things kind of
make sense we go from captain marvel to
iron man iron man 2 but then we're
stopped again by a marvel one shot this
one is titled a funny thing happened on
the way to thor's hammer it's a little
short about three minutes long that
shows agent coulson on his way to the
middle of the desert to go find thor's
hammer on his way he stops to get gas
and then the gas station is robbed well
he's a trained shield agent so i'll let
you guess how that one ends if you
haven't seen it so that is the sixth
thing you need to watch with the very
first thor film being the seventh we are
then interrupted again by a one shot
called the consultant it's a three
minute clip of agent coulson and sitwell
conspiring to stop general ross from
meddling and shield affairs and they get
tony stark involved and once we are
passed this one shot we are now set to
watch the very first avengers film this
takes place after the events of the very
first avengers film where shield is
recovering all of the items of the
chitari they recover all of them except
for one item 47. it turns out a couple
has found it and they are using it to
rob banks but then after that we watch
thor the dark world and then iron man 3.
now iron man 3 had the fake mandarin he
returned in shanghai and the legend of
the ten rings and if you were wondering
what kind of happened after iron man 3
and before shang chi then you can watch
the short all hail the king and this
pretty much wraps it up for the one shot
list they pretty much ended their one
shots after all hail the king so from
here we just dive into the true
chronological order of movies and shows
so after thor the dark world iron man 3
and all hell the king we get into
captain america the winter soldier and
after captain america the winter soldier
i've heard a lot of debate on what
should come next and gets a little bit
muddy but here's the proper order
guardians of the galaxy vol 1
immediately followed by guardians of the
galaxy vol 2. those are the
chronological order of events in the mcu
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 then
volume 2 immediately followed by the
avengers age of ultron then we have our
very first ant-man film after that we
have captain america civil war now
captain america civil war set up a few
different films the three films being
black widow black panther and spider-man
homecoming now disney plus has the order
listed after captain america civil war
as you watch black widow next and then
black panther now as far as when
spider-man homecoming takes place there
was a really big debate this is because
there is a mistake in the film in the
prologue of the movie it states that it
takes place eight years after the battle
of new york which is wrong because that
would mean the film takes place in 2020
which we know it doesn't and the
president of marvel studios has
confirmed that that was an error in
avengers infinity war tony stark states
that it's been six years since the
battle of new york meaning infinity war
which takes place after spider-man
homecoming takes place in 2018. so this
would mean that the events of spider-man
homecoming take place in 2017 or
2018. and again this is not on the
official chronological order on disney
plus because sony owns the rights to the
film so after civil war it says black
widow black panther and then dr strange
after that we have thor ragnarok and
this is where things really build up to
thanos and one would think that thor
ragnarok was the last film right before
infinity war because thanos shows up at
the end and infinity war pretty much
picks up where thor ragnarok left off
but you have to watch ant-man and the
wasp before avengers infinity war that
is how disney plus lists the
chronological order and that is because
the entire film of ant-man and the wasp
actually takes place before infinity war
it is only the post-credit that takes
place during infinity war several months
have passed between the actual movie and
the events of the post-credits scene so
watch ant-man and the wasp right before
avengers infinity war and of course like
i've been stating you then watch
avengers infinity war and then of course
you watch avengers in-game immediately
after now from here we get into marvel's
phase 4 which introduces the disney plus
shows which are all canon to the mcu
they all happen within the mcu and
according to disney plus chronological
timeline the project to watch after
avengers in-game is the loki series i
think many people expected one division
to be the next project right after
because it's the first one that we got
but remember there was a lot of
rescheduling going on because of the
pandemic so after avengers in game you
watch the loki series from there you
watch marvel's what if now some people
think that what if might be irrelevant
on the mcu timeline but remember it all
connects and i wouldn't be surprised if
we actually see some of these characters
from marvel's what if in multiverse of
madness because anything is possible and
this animated universe is just simply a
different universe in the multiverse so
after marvel's what if then we have one
division immediately after that we have
the falcon and the winter soldier then
we have shang qi and the legend of the
tin rings then we have marvel's eternals
and then we have the hawkeye series now
of course the two films that are missing
here are spider-man fire from home and
spider-man no way home and based off of
what we know about where the film takes
place it takes place in the winter of
2024
now we're not really sure where hawkeye
takes place but it either takes place
right before christmas in 2024 or in
2025 either way the events of spider-man
no way home happened before christmas we
know this because mj is taking down the
halloween decorations which means it
takes place right after halloween before
christmas so either way the events of
spider-man far from home and no way home
should take place before the hawkeye
series making hawkeye the very last
project of marvel studios's
chronological order up until this point
of course and this according to disney
plus and which of course is marvel is
the right chronological order to watch
the mcu i know there's been a lot of
debate between fans on what the actual
order is so if you disagree with this
and you have a different order be sure
to let me know in the comments down
below and if you're planning on watching
the entire mcu saga all over again
here's how to do it so let me know what
you think about this video and the order
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof